a dramatic political standoff in Britain
could bring down the government of
America's closest ally today British
Prime Minister Theresa May is facing a
challenge from within her own party over
how she's handled the brexit plan to
withdraw from the European Union next
year right now May is facing lawmakers
in Parliament short time ago she vowed
to fight to keep her job so there will
now be a vote of confidence in my
leadership of the Conservative Party
I will contest that vote with everything
I've got
if May loses it will leave Britain
without a leader Mark Phillips is
outside the houses of parliament in
London with the latest mark good morning
good morning well just when you thought
that the long and twisted road toward
Britain leaving the European Union
couldn't get any lumpier it just had
this vote that Theresa May is facing
today was as you say initiated by
members of her own party those people in
the party it took 48 of them who felt
that the deal that she had worked out
with the European Union the divorce
settlement if you will was not strong
enough gave too many concessions would
not result in an independent enough
Britain in their view now they forced
the vote she has to carry a majority of
the MPS the Conservative MPs in
Parliament in a vote that will be held
this evening but this is a lose-lose
proposition for her if she loses the
vote she's out if she wins the vote no
matter how much she's weakened by the
very process of the challenge to her all
of this happening is the deadline toward
Britain leaving the EU which is in next
March ticks away Theresa May has tried
to get further concessions from the EU
this vote against her today for the week
ends that process as well all right mark
Philips in London thank you Mark